[Applause]
welcome just right from the FASTA games
Awards here's what's coming up for you
in the next ten minutes we'll be telling
you who won what and why Chris brings
you the high points from the biggest
night in the gaming calendar the man who
has that bastard Games Committee tells
me why they thought in a new category
this year and the rest of the best can
brings you his review of the title good
didn't win best game but need to be on
your radar it happens every year and
swype wouldn't miss it for the world the
BAFTA games Awards an event that
celebrates the best video games of the
past year and the people who made them
so here's Chris with the winners
everybody's been talking about this
year's BAFTA for best game came as
something of a shock amazingly what we
made the video face the independent
title scooped the big prize
there are a lot of stories people tell
about the Finch family most of them and
strictly the mystery adventure game was
developed by a small team defying a
trend which normally sees the big Triple
A games take home the award this one is
mine tonight shows you don't have to
make things that try to please everybody
you know try to make something that
pleases yourself and I mean there I
think is the community out there that
will appreciate that you know whatever
it is the thing that you're interested
in she will save his son the big winner
on the night though was he'll blades so
new was sacrificed by Ninja Theory the
cambridge-based company claimed five
awards for the game including Best
British title and they also won in a
whole new category game beyond
entertainment marking a wider
contribution to society the game sort of
went away from being a game in fact you
know the word game is sort of doesn't
really work for hell-blood it's more
like an experience and it's an
experience that just seemed to resonate
with a lot of people because mental
illness is not something that only other
people certainly show people in our
society suffer from it's something that
we all experience at some point in our
lives and the more and and I think
people recognized it within the game and
the actress behind the game's
protagonist also won best performance
her story is an unconventional route to
fame I was a video editor from Ninja
Theory since 2012 and I was working on
Devil May Cry and held late shooting
behind the scenes and when the actress
were held late
ended up taking on a different role they
asked me if I could jump in for some
tech experiments and so I tried on the
suit at the helmet and elsewhere on the
night Nintendo took home three awards
for the latest entries into the Mario
and Zelda franchises and best
multiplayer went to divinity original
sin - another shock given the massively
popular title fortnight was up to the
award that wraps it up for the BAFTA
game award thread ad so this year's
ceremony was a win for the underdog
Chris Creegan Sky News there was a
change to this year's event the
introduction of a whole new category
called game beyond entertainment it
recognized the titles delivering what
BAFTA calls a transformational
experience beyond pure entertainment and
to explain what that means a little
earlier I caught up with a man who heads
up BAFTAs games committee this is a new
category that we've launched this year
and it's very exciting for us because
we're recognizing the emotional response
that games can create in people we're
recognizing that that you can do these
wonderful emotional stories you can you
can cause people to think in different
ways
[Music]
we have a game this year in the category
called burying my love it's about a
Syrian couple they are separated one of
them manages to escape to another
country and it's then the interaction
between these two people I'm tearing up
even think about it it's impossible to
play this game and not feel for these
are just normal people in difficult
circumstances
[Music]
last date June is it's it's almost like
a redemption story for the person that
made it there they have a tragedy that
they dealt with and they're looking at
could different things have happened
could do things that they do could that
have changed the outcome I'm sure it was
cathartic for them as a maker but
they've created such an emotional
response with it
but it's not all about emotional
responses sometimes it's about doing
good things doing important things we
have Seaquest which is collating a bunch
of data which is going to support
alzheimer's research is there something
about video games that make them a
better medium for being impactful
compared to watching a movie
for example movies are fantastic you
know I'm part up after and we love films
but because you're playing a game
because you're in that game it means
that the the outcomes of what you're
seeing come from from what you did and
it means you have to have those moral
quandaries you're not sitting there as a
passenger you are creating the story and
in creating the story you're creating
the outcome so why now why this year
bring in that new category so it's been
a trend we've seen more and more games
which deal with things that matter we've
seen that trend and it feels now is the
right time to start to recognize that
trend there's enough one of the things
we have to do it better we have to know
that there's going to be enough games of
enough quality in any category we felt
really confident that this year there
were going to be enough games of enough
quality that we wanted to recognize them
[Music]
on the night it was hell-blade sin you a
sacrifice that one adding to its Hall of
awards the games central celtic warrior
character struggles with mental health
issues
it was developed with the help of
neuroscientists as well as people who've
experienced psychosis and games is a way
of telling a story and every creative
has a story that they want to tell and
these people that have made these games
they've taken their story they've put
their heart and soul into creating this
experience and we're lucky enough to be
able to share that experience with them
so you already know who took the best
game award but with such a high caliber
mix in that category we wanted to tell
you a little bit more about some of the
other titles that didn't take the big
prize and to do that here's a man who's
played them all Arivu account
[Music]
so one of the games that was nominated
for a best game or Super Mario Odyssey
and if you don't played it you really
must it's one of the greatest I think
Mario games ever made
now crucial was the addition of capi
which is a cap that Mario wears you can
throw on to other characters in the game
allowing you to control them this
combined with just stunning environments
and the usual kanna charm and humor that
always goes with Mario makes this a
fantastic game Assassin's Creed origins
in my mind it is the greatest Assassin's
Creed game ever made even better than
Brotherhood oh yes
the reason being is the setting it's set
in ancient Egypt so you can explore
Alexandria you can literally climb the
pyramids which are perfectly recreated
but most important of all is the
gameplay they've really evolved at
Sasson screed and brought in elements
from other fantastic games like The
Witcher 3 and this makes the fantastic
experience feel like a good open world
adventure one of the other games
nominated for best game is the Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild which is
nothing short of a masterpiece whether
it's the huge varied environments or
they're really quite challenging combat
this game is exceptional the best thing
though is when you just head off into
the wilderness and explore because you
never know what adventures you're gonna
find really is a great game must check
it out
well that's it for this week's show
don't forget to join us again for more
swype next week and in the meantime why
not follow us on twitter at sky news
swipe then you can see what we get up to
throughout the week bye bye
you
[Applause]
[Music]